[Musik]
wir sind die zehn jahres am neusiedler
see ich hinter mir seht ihr auch den
neusiedler see und hinter mir das leiter
gibt werke zweiter gebirge hat eine ganz
lange tradition hier stehen überall
kirschbäume und hinter mir insgesamt
etwa 5000 stück früher hat hier der
winter nämlich nicht durch den
weinverkauf sein geld verdient sondern
durch den verkauf von kirschen in der
letzten sendung war das steiermark und
habe dort gelernt wie steirisches
kürbiskernöl hergestellt wird
wenn ihr das kürbiskernöl nicht nur für
eine cremige kürbissuppe verwenden
möchte sondern ganz kreative ideen sucht
dann schaut euch gerne mal mein letztes
video aus österreich worden und ich bin
jetzt hier weit ist keine kirschen
verkaufen und auch keinen wein sondern
ich treffe jetzt gleich den sieben und
her
simon ist nämlich imker und ihnen werde
ich heute besuchen er zeigt mir nämlich
heute seine bienenstöcke
willkommen wenn bienen so ich hab das
gedicht danke für die einladung gerne
brauchen schutz ja zum schutz kümmern
es ist nicht nur in filmen so dass man
an zu gebrauchen sondern auch wegen oder
sagt gespürt wie es ist simca mit einem
pin system
ich helfe dir deine hand die andere hand
und ausland geschafft
[Musik]
wir starten unsere erste mondlandung als
kabine habe ich eigentlich keine angst
weil die ja eigentlich nichts machen
da habe ich schon gesagt hat sie können
schon noch stärker
allerdings nur dann wenn sie wirklich
sagte ja so und dann sterben sie auch
gerne leider schon
es ist so traurig deswegen sind wir ganz
lieb zu den bienen
das sind so die gründer beispiel zeigen
ist fertig angezogen jetzt helfen jeder
bienenstock besteht aus einem dach und
den kästen ganz unten ist der flug
bereit
dann kommt die brut und darüber liegen
die hohlräume
wichtig ist immer dass man sich einen
bienenstock von hinten nähert also nicht
am flugbereich sondern hinten damit die
bienen eben nicht auf geschäft werden im
bienenstock wird es nie über 40 grad
warm denn die bienen können ganz alleine
den videos stock herunter kühlen in
einem bienenstock können etwa 5000 bis
40.000 bienen leben je nach größe des
bienenstocks ist der wassergehalt im
honig zu holen dann ist dir aber noch
offen
sobald der eingelagerte honig den
idealen wassergehalt hat verschließen
die bienen die waren dann weiß der imker
auch dass der honig bereit ist für die
ernte
sobald sie zu zwei drittel verdeckt ist
kann man sie mit nach hause nehmen kann
schleudern weil das ist dann auch ein
honig in schönwald hat er der schweiz
ist und sich lange hält im glas ich hab
mal gelesen dass honig so zu den
einzigen lebensmitteln gehört was
unendlich halt wenn man es richtig
lagert ja es wurde das auch von den
ägyptern auch er ab kann man ohne
gefunden machen viele viele tausend
milliarde alter aber dennoch liegen wir
noch essbar und und du musst aber auch
wissen wenn ich jetzt die scheidung
würde kann ich das rennen nicht einfach
so reingehen
ich muss das geld ja mal mit bienen
befreien
dafür habe ich einen ganzen fans ist das
kriegen sie ein schleudertrauma die
bienen werden also vor dem schleudern
ganz behutsam von den waffen getrennt
und dann kann der honig bereits
geschleudert werden möchte schon schwer
das gewicht von bis zu zwei kilogramm
kann das schwer werden
gleich
ich spaziere den bienenstock gesehen und
simon hat mir ein bisschen war es ihre
seine entstehungsgeschichte erzählt
jetzt gehen wir zu ihm nach hause
den honig hat er bereits abgefüllt und
zeigt mir jetzt gleich zu verschiedenen
honigsorten und erklärt mir ihre
besonderheiten
jetzt aber beim 7 und zu hause den honig
hast du schon abgeführt das können wir
jetzt nicht sehen aber ich habe schon
das fertige produkt genau hier beginnt
gleich mit dieser service das ist mein
versprechen honig er ist der hat er auch
früher entsteht hat in ihm stecken die
ganzen frühlingsboten drehen man auch
die ganzen kirschblüten und hier im
erzgebirge und er ist für mich so der
gentleman ist eine cremige der bilder
und auch das ist eigentlich vielleicht
ein bisschen typisch fürs frühjahr weil
ich früher noch nicht so viel strom
strom geld und es spiegelt sich im juni
wider
das klingt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
schräg aber als der honig menschen die
nicht denn honig freuen kann man so
sagen weil ich zur typisch nach honig
schmeckt erinnert 15 und traubenzucker
vielleicht neue ob sie dem zug erreichen
sogar drei wirklich gehen die kirche
bitte verblüht ist wird der bienenstock
geschleudert und wird hier in diesen
käse abgewählt allez allez les und
diesem moment beginnt anschließend der
karte zu blühen und der ganze ist jetzt
unser nächstes gläschen wein blüht der
blütenhonig mit der garten holen
ja es jetzt ein flüssiger honig und
adwords oder verspielte er ist auch
etwas süßer weil fruchtzucker ist
wiederum der fruchtzucker reich
fruchtzucker hat und wir ein süßes card
sehr sehr klar unsere kunden ca drei
wochen wieder im nachbarzelt gedachte er
geschleudert und alles was einem
hochsommer blüht und kommt in der natur
wird dann hier eingetragen
dieses kissen von sabine er es da wild
blütenhonig er seinen macho der kräftige
aromatisch starke es ist zwar ein
blütenhonig aber erinnert schon ein
bisschen anwalt
eine gewisse schwere schon hat hier ist
der hochsommer trinken lernt hier mit
dem messer sonst und es bildet sich ein
bisschen komisch versteht auch warum es
verschiedene honigsorten gibt man
einfach im frühjahr als andere aufwächst
im hochsommer und dann nochmal im sommer
auf ihrem winter im intels im gepäck und
persönliche jahr von ihnen kuscheln sich
die pläne zusammen geht wird gekuschelt
einig und früher mit den ersten blüten
es draußen in der natur faire
arbeitsbedingungen selbst mit ihnen die
können im winterurlaub machen
sally hast du schon mal gefragt warum
honige flüssig sind oder cremig sind das
wäre eigentlich meine nächste frage an
dich gewähren
und auch keine ahnung gehabt was hat
gesagt das was mit zucker zu honige die
sehr lange flügel sollte ja hier sind
honig es ist ja fruchtzucker reicht sind
bekannte nämlich keine kristalle und
honige bisher schnell cremig werden sehr
schnell fest werden
das sind einige dieser traum zu bereich
sind und glauben zu bekannt ist dass
alle bögen also daher auch genauso wie
der ja genau
ein kleiner tipp vom imker jetzt wenn
man eine fruktose intoleranz hat und es
ist immer besser man greift erholung
sehr cremig südwesten sind womit der
trauben zu bereich sind und die sind
vielfältig diese menschen noch
verträglich weil wir da also eine
fruktose intoleranz hatte er zu einem
cremigen honig greifen weil die trauben
sogar in das stadt vor zucker was mich
jetzt aber noch interessiert simon warum
heißt denn dein honig lilly sony wenn
ich sehe wie man sich gut gefangen seine
tochter eines tages will ich für mich
mir sehr gespielt da echt freche name
ist oder soll ich schenken klar denn
nach faust die kinder verloren wenn sie
es
auch der name hat
auf jeden fall will aber gut gefallen
das bild war willi war im internet schon
längst geben
das hast du mir bekommen ohne teufel
mehrheit gegeben so gemacht doch jetzt
raus mit ipsen uns auch geschrieben also
was im internet nach 3b domain und ein
und ein weiterer freunde grafiker ist
hat mir dann gesagt das ist doch bekannt
dass er mit beamer draufsetzen und wer
seine spiele entstanden ist die blume
und die ließ gene und darauf wird honig
[Musik]
sagt sie auch gleich gehalten danken war
sogar so mit wasser kurzen lager da kann
man gleich honig probieren ja jetzt
haben hier deine produkte und du hast ja
bewusst dafür entschieden seine produkte
beim intersport so genau weil
gewerblichen sehr viel bekommen bei mir
mit meiner kindheit familie früh an
jeder stelle erinnern gilt mit dem
briten aus und dann wieder die tasche
folge verliehen gründen aus jeder wird
sich auch das wir sind dann hatte ich
war chips und eine toilette ist mehr
aber das fleisch soll und damit nach
sehr schönen erinnerungen
und deshalb musste ich auch wieder an
diese kooperation zusammen mit dem das
für mich auch leicht innerlich
schmunzeln weil es schön dass ich auch
eines tages auch intersport drin sein
werde
und ich find's einfach toll das
intersport die lokalen produzenten wie
dich auf jeden fall nach unterstützt
werden also vielen dank dafür so viel
über honig gelernt und wenn natürlich
jetzt wunderschön wenn man noch was wenn
meine zuschauer hätten wir wirklich sind
dann könnt ihr jetzt eine frage
beantworten die frage wird euch gleich
dass simon schnell und dann könnt ihr
hier nämlich auch auf der
genau die frage heißt waren hessen comic
release also wenn ihr gut aufgepasst hat
könnte die frage bestimmt beantworten
bekommt ein richtig schönes ruhig paket
simon vielen dank ich nehme mir gerne
ein gläschen honig mit und vielleicht
gibt es ja keinen honig auch mal
irgendwann bei uns in deutschland
glücklich vollgepackt führen dazu hat
mich sehr geprägt nicht auch danke dir
es kommt schon bald sind wir schon fast
honig experten und wer weiß vielleicht
haben wir ja auch irgendwann einen
eigenen bienenstock wir fahren jetzt vom
neusiedlersee direkt nach frauenkirchen
und werden dort etwas über diese
besondere blüten erfahren
[Musik]
recht
vorstand dem break
[Musik]